c'était particulier dans votre travail
très original c'est que pierre fait des
photos et gilles les retouches
c'est vrai que je passe dans les photos
plus jean-pierre fait la white brûle
mais on file des corps est où ta
conception que la conception du guide
l'idée c'est plus que peindre
sur notre photo à pierre et qu'on dit
qu'on veut la photo comme ça ça marche
pas donc là tu puisses travail et
surtout surtout jours on peut que
travailler linverse aussi ont fait le
travail en cassation 12e travailler
ensemble ouais j'ai créé tout un univers
qu'on peut appeler un peu la planète
puis à gilles quoi vous avez une phrase
pour dire ça c'est n'importe où hors du
monde vous avez un peu fui comme ça là
la réalité et vous peignez des univers
sublimer complètement quand est ce qu'on
peut dire à port of en temps on s'en
rend pas compte tout ce pognon c'est un
univers l'univers qui sort au fond de
nous on sait pas d'où ça vient mais
on laisse les choses venir comme ça
comme on le ressent on n'essaye pas de
d'analysé de
ce qui nous intéresse on travaille c'est
ce qu'on comprend pas qui nous est cher
cousin vendée u ckoi propre plein de
choses plein de chocs le voyage beaucoup
de voyages tout la télévision et les
magazines lorient si les médias
si les maliens coucou à 10 n'est pas
aussi oui aussi des calendriers des ptt
or moi ils sont pas les boîtes de
chocolat il y en a des belles balades
est belle en découvert ce mois ci dans
actuelle une série que vous êtes en
train de faire absolument génial surtout
maintenant vous attaquez après avoir
fait du des personnages des personnages
types des militaires des marins des
côtes françois des là vous en êtes
maintenant vous êtes au saint des saints
leur raconter un peu
il ressemble d'ailleurs dé saint des
saints ouais voici donc arrivés augmente
à séron sait pas trop comment ça nous
est venue mais dans nos images qu'en
faisait le naufrage avait des pleureuses
des images comme ça souvent dû les gens
disent exerçant blind sainte vierge et
des choses comme ça puis on pensait
depuis longtemps faire des on adore les
images ont été battus gens à côté un peu
saint sulpiciens ce que vous faisiez
ouais ça soutient ce sport du lycée dans
camping
il réalise et qui a un côté toujours un
peu
je pars un peu
les gens sont un peu en dehors du son en
dehors des réalités un peu devant aix
maldives un méchant quand vous passez du
temps comme ça à faire des saints et des
saintes c'est uniquement pour la forme
ou derrière il ya une vraie foi vous
avais-je pas moins retrouvé la fois
peut-être on doit quand on fait des
camps 3 est rentrée en tout cas mais
l'alternance que vous faite j'en suis
sûr mais la voie en dieu là pour servir
et hier ça va avec tout la foi la foi
c'est croire c'est croire complètement
sans dérision dans les choses vraiment
parce qu'on les hait non y croit et tout
va ensemble lourde et combien vos photos
on n'aime pas tellement parler d'argent
bien en jambes en avant les effets de
l'alcool
vous voyez pas vous d'argent ça dépend
des fois je suis sûr vous rendez
bienvenus huawei
mais on on pense pas beaucoup à l'argent
on consomme quoi
je vais bien quand même pas où ça va ça
coûte combien si par exemple je sais pas
ma cousine se faire faire un portrait de
bar vous faites des gens comme ça si on
l'est on peut la faire pour le plaisir
parce que on a envie que c'est un peu la
fête pas vous lâcher avant de payer cher
et puis gêné nous plaît pas enlacer
ponot recul on peut voir votre travail
en ce moment en ce moment c'est la
galerie samia aux mains des caisses
convoi ont volé son pistolet sur le
thème des saints celle qu'elle préférait
on les aime tous mais j'aime bien sûr
françois d'assise pourquoi of charlie
aux oiseaux pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous il
m'était impossible